this was what John Kirby the National
Security Council spokesman just said at
the white house the other day he said
that LGBT
LMNOP ideology is now a a key aspect of
American foreign policy and Biden has
been nothing but consistent uh about his
uh belief foundational belief in human
rights and lgbtq plus rights are human
rights and we again back to the earlier
question we're never going to shy away
and be bashful about speaking up for
those rights and for uh for individuals
to live as they deem fit as they want to
live and that's something that's a core
part of our foreign policy and it will
remain that's a core part of our foreign
policy
transgenderism is a core part of our
foreign policy then call me an
isolationist I guess